(light upbeat music)
- [Dan] It's like a
symphony of manipulating
and spinning and flipping
the cards in your hands.
It's like each move inspires the next
and you're not even thinking about it.
The cards are dancing between the hands,
they're spinning around,
they're flipping over,
they're doing things
you wouldn't even expect them to be doing.
(light upbeat music)
It's just so surprising, almost magical.
(light dramatic music)
(light upbeat music)
For as long as I can remember
we've always done things
in tandem together.
We both got into magic
around the age of 12,
we would go to the library
and check out books
by Dai Vernon, Guy Hollingworth,
just seeing the illustrations were like,
wow, we can do this with playing cards?
When we started practicing
cardistry, it wasn't a thing,
it has its roots in magic,
it comes from card magicians,
who would use what is
called a card flourish
and these were used to accentuate
certain moments in a magic trick,
so we took that and just ran with it.
We were the first to embrace
it and really focus on it
and practice it as its own thing
and promote it as its own thing.
(light dynamic music)
Cardistry is very much like skateboarding,
you know, we practice these tricks
until we have them down perfect, you know,
we see other tricks and we're
like, oh, we gotta learn that,
you know, 52 playing cards
and the possibilities to maneuver
those around are endless.
You can hold a deck of cards in your hand
and it's one solid block,
now imagine lifting up another block,
so now you have two,
well, what can you do with
those two blocks in your hands?
Well, you can create more
blocks and we call those packets
and you can start maneuvering and spinning
and flipping those packets
between your fingers.
It's hard, like it takes
a lot of dexterity,
it's all practiced, it's all rehearsed
and when you're truly a master,
you can just start doing things on the fly
and you don't even have to think about it.
(light upbeat music)
What kids are doing today
with cards is mind blowing,
if you would have told me
that when I was 14 years old,
I would have been like,
that's the coolest thing,
I had no idea that it
could even be this big.
The ultimate goal would be
to get people to almost
put cardistry first,
when they see a deck of playing cards,
you know, it's no longer for games,
it's no longer for
gambling, it's cardistry.
(light upbeat music)